This is Radiolab. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
I'm Soren Wheeler and this
[inaudible]. Alright, if you want to sit there. Okay.
If you stick the phones on and start saying I to someone and I don't know,
can you hear anyone? Can I hear anyone? Oh No. Can you hear anyone? Oh my God,
sorry. And Hi. Yes I do.
I do this a Sally 80 she's an old friend of mine. How are you?
We went to school together long time ago,
but these days she's an editor at New Scientist in London and the reason I
called her into the studio is because of something that happened to her when she
was working on the story for them. Yes.
This was a story that I'd been chasing for years and years again for her in 2007
at DARPA Tech,
which is a big gathering of like weapons developers and researchers.
It's like 5,000 guys. I'll, you know, looking like agent Smith from the Matrix,
you know, looking at the, the latest war toys, drones, Bazookas. Anyway,
at some point she starts talking to this woman and she was telling me about her
program,
which was that they had figured out how to apply sort of electrical current to
the brain in order to accelerate the learning process. And I was like,
nope.
So what Sally had stumbled into with something called PDCs scans for
transcranial direct current stimulation.
The idea is you take a couple of little electrodes,
you place them on your scalp, connected with wires to a battery,
you send a little bit of electricity into your brain and then
all kinds of things happen if you believe the claims. But um, for Sally,
it started with a casual afternoon of sniper training.
So after that conversation at the conference,
she tracked down a group in Carlsbad, California.
It's about an hour and a half south of La who are using this brain zapping stuff
to train snipers.
And I actually got new scientists to agreed to send me to La from London,
which is not an insignificant expense.
After a late night international flight and some la traffic, I haven't slept,
I'm sleep deprived.
Sally found herself at a place called advanced brain monitoring where they have
a little room,
this little room where they've set up a little sort of 360 degree training
simulation. So it's kind of like a video game, but um,
it's like the full kind of like the full room in front of you.
And so wall is a screen. Yes. Not only that, she says,
but all around you in this room are these props. You're behind real sandbags,
you know, in proper position.
They teach you how to hold the rifle properly and the rifle,
except for the fact that it shoots blanks, it's basically the real deal. Yeah.
And then it's got a laser laser site and they tell her, you know, okay,
before we do this brain stimulation thing,
we're actually going to have you do some training without it.
So they get her all set up, they put her behind the sandbags and they hit go.
You know, at first it starts out with really easy stuff.
Like you're shooting virtual targets that aren't people. Then it's quite,
it's realistic.
You get the kickback from the CO2 cartridge and then you get this like sound
from when you hit,
you know the metal target and then it starts getting harder so there's people
instead of targets and then more and more people until the highest level is you
are at a checkpoint,
like an Iraqi checkpoint and everything's fine and then all of a sudden
the Humvee in front of you blows up and then from all over the place does people
in suicide bomb fast start running at you with their rifles shooting you and I'm
just being blown up. I can't,
I can't make the decisions fast enough.
She said there were just too many of them.
She couldn't figure out who to shoot first. It was so, oh God.
And I was so tired and I was so jet lagged and I was so bad at it and it's funny
because you think like, oh, whatever, that's a video game,
but it's amazing how stressful that gets. In a certain point,
stress started getting to her. It was like, all right, stop,
let's just end this. She started thinking like,
what the hell am I doing here anyway? Like, oh my God,
this isn't going to be a story.
And really you just flew out to California for this.
She was not very good at it and it kind of stressed her out.
And then this guy walked in the room. Yes, Mike Weissen. Mike Weisen,
he's a neuroscientist. It looks like Greg Allman.
He's got that like super long hair. Fairly clean cut at the moment.
But I had hair down to my belt buckle.
So Mike Wisen has put together this contraption.
What is the big box is sitting in your lap there?
This is a big red toolbox that we got literally from Sears.
Mike was actually passing through New York City,
so we invited him into the studio and we have electrodes, uh,
that allow us to deliver current.
You have a bunch of wires I saw in a whole bunch of batteries.
So we take a set of electrodes.
One electrode is attached to my right temple and the other electrode is attached
by a different wire to my, uh, left arm.
We turn on the juice. Did it hurt?
It wasn't so much that I suddenly tasted metal in my mouth. It tasted,
it tasted like I had like the inside of an aluminum can. And then he's like,
all right, try it again. I'm like, ah,
I'm not exactly expecting different results. So they, they start me out again,
right at the really hard check 0.1, the thing blows up and then, um,
people start coming from all over the place and I feel like they must've put it
on an easy setting. Everything is just a little more straightforward.
It's more obvious who I should pick off first.
And I'm thinking to myself a little bit like, you know,
when is this going to get really hard again? And then the [inaudible], well,
you know, intern or whoever comes in and turns on the lights, she's like, okay,
you're done. I'm like, well wait, that's not,
that's not what I fully been here for like three minutes. She's like, no, no,
no, no. That was 20 minutes. I'm like, no, that's not true.
And I look up in the clocks of all shifted by 20 minutes and I swear to God it
was three minutes.
Almost every person that we put this on says they get into what they call a
state of flow where they don't recognize that time has gone by.
They're just boom, boom, boom, boom. And I was like,
did you guys make it easier? They're like, no. Same, same, uh, level.
I'm like,
I think you guys made it easy when Sally did it with brain stimulation,
she performed at 100% accuracy. 100%.
I didn't leave anyone alive. And how, what was she before? Uh, I don't know,
but she wasn't very good at roughly three out of 20 the first time in 20 out of
20 in second. Yeah. So wait, so you're saying with just a little electricity,
she went from being like totally inept to like a trained killer? Well,
it's an n of one so we can't go too far.
But I mean this was just Sally's experience during this one demo.
So it's not like a controlled study,
but Mike has now used this device in a bunch of studies for the military.
For example,
you had one study with people looking at those grainy black and white radar
images trying to pick out, you know, what's an enemy vehicle and what isn't?
And if he puts this device on their head while they're trying to learn how to do
that, we can double the rate of learning really well. How, I mean,
what is it doing? Okay,
so what I think is that early on when you are learning something,
Mike says that when you're trying to learn how to do something that's kind of
tough. What's happening is that you're trying a bunch of different things.
You try all kinds of different ways to solve the problem and occasionally your
brain is stumbling across an ideal sequence of neurons.
Every so often as you're practicing, all of a sudden your brain is like, oh,
this then this, then this and this. Okay, that's it.
But then it struggles to find that again and it keeps messing up and whatever.
And if you look at an expert brain,
you'll actually see that preferred circuit dialed in.
Like they just do that over and over and over again. No more stumbling around.
And so what Mike does is he figures out where that circuit is and he gives it a
little extra
juice to an in essence prime the pump so that that expert circuit is more likely
to fire and you're more likely to stumble into it.
And when you do stumble into it, you're more likely to stick with it.
That's right. That's how we think it works. But are you,
are you sure of what you're hitting?
I mean like you're putting electricity on the outside of people's heads.
So are you able to target just a small cluster of brain cells or is it a region
that you're hitting or like a thousand cells? What I'm bragging,
what I'm talking about is millions of cells. That's how, that's a lot. Yeah.
Is that precise enough to,
to target the place where a task is being done in a brain? If it's a million,
uh, in our work, yes. And Mike claims that even though it's a blunt tool, yeah,
this is not a scalpel. This is sledge hammer.
If you know the right group of neurons or region of the brain to target,
this can work with almost any task.
If you want to target a visual spatial learning,
for example, searching an image,
you'd put this on the right side of your head roughly near the temple,
but if you wanted to learn textual material,
you can put this on the left side of your head and it will have a similar
effect. If you wanted to learn textual here, be true. No,
I mean I'm, if I want to learn irregular verbs in French,
I get one of your things. I stick it in the part of my hair,
but as good as for grammar,
we haven't tested it in with learning foreign languages,
but if a native English speaker is learning a long English sentence,
they can recall it with greater fidelity.
If they have this on their head while they study those sentences and if you go
right parietal back over just behind your ear and up above your ear,
you can learn math better.
We were all Kinda like, Eh, I don't know.
But since Mike had his device there with them, should we try it? Sure,
I'm ready. We thought, no, let's try it and see for ourselves.
Do you want to do it right? I mean,
I had Robert Actually pretended he has an appointment.
He left but me taking them to the team here, I don't do fear,
right. Don't need to be seated for this or yes, you should be seated. All right,
stick around because we are going to put electricity right into the man's head
and I'm talking about Chad
[inaudible].
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got invest in our planet while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our resources are diminishing,
our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies,
working towards clean water when you will bill energy. And Green Technology.
It's a market opportunity. You can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your account at swell,
investing.com/radiolab.
All right, so you've got here in front of me, you have two little circles.
Electrodes is that these are, Yup. Red Wires and black wire.
So I get two of these on my head. One on your upper arm,
one on my upper arm
for the demo call. My, uh, Mike showed me a bunch of stereograms. Alright,
so what am I doing here?
I'm looking at a bunch of marbles and million of them in some kind of repeating
patterns. Like, you know, these things forever.
Like where are you staring at this two d picture of like, uh, I don't know,
the repeating pattern of marbles or something.
And you're supposed to unfocus your eyes and just the right way so that a three
d picture will surmount merge from the background. Yeah. Excuse me.
We need make me, my eyes go batty. So the idea of this demo was like,
let's see if I can train my eyes to figure out how to pull the three d picture
out.
You see it? I didn't get it. I ain't getting nothing.
I have never been good at these. I mean,
I get headaches when I go to three d movies and it took me like 10 minutes to
one Ah,
butterfly. There he is.
Whoa, that's cool too. To see like just one. Wow. Look at this. All right,
so now you can juice me. Use this system. All right, I'm going to turn it on.
Okay. Okay. I don't feel anything yet. Oh yeah. Okay. There it is. Ah,
what is it feeling?
It feels like a bunch of mosquitoes are biting me in my temple. It's slough.
I could taste it now too,
so people would get that, huh? All right, so now I'm gonna,
I'm gonna look at the stereoscopic images one more time. Here we are.
We've got a green and pink
that just became the world that suddenly a 3d globe just pops out of the
background. Okay, next one.
All right. So now I'm looking at a big green grass
blades of grass repeating, repeating, repeating. Let's see. Well,
swans, IC, swans, Origami, swans, 3d swans. Next one.
Now I'm looking at a good sort of a trippy Paisley background and
Sandy 3d Bambi. Next one.
Right now we have flower background. Should have the yellow and pink flower.
Thailand background.
Whoa. Boxes, boxes floating in space. Next. Whoa.
A little ballerina doing a handstand on the balance beam. Robots.
Little Hershey's cases popping right now. Yes.
They're coming out really fast.
[inaudible] big pretzel yeses. Awesome. Coiled snake.
Cool. Anyway, wow. That's the,
that's what it feels like to get your brain juice stuff. Okay.
I definitely felt like I couldn't, you couldn't give them to me fast enough.
I was like, oh, it's like another one, another one, another one.
So maybe that's a flow state like you were describing. I don't know.
I feel very, very awake. Okay.
So in the end I ended up doing something like 50 stereograms in a really short
amount of time. Great. Wow. So I definitely think something was going on,
but I have to be honest. I mean I was skeptical.
You were skeptical even when you were flying free. Well, it's like it's,
I don't entirely trust the experience I had cause it could simply be like a
placebo could be adrenaline. I Dunno. Yeah, I mean that's the thing. It just,
no matter what it just seems like the next flavor of new age.
Well, Hey, I started calling around.
Uh,
my name is Peter Reiner and I'm professor at the University of British Columbia.
Cool. So, so Peter Reiner actually studies this whole field.
He looks at public perception and the quality of research.
And I just basically asked him, you know, is this for real?
Like if you have a healthy brain, you put a little electricity into it.
Has it been proven that that will enhance learning or whatever else they claim?
Well,
maybe the best way to answer that is that part of the reason that there's all
this interest is that tdcs appears to be relatively effective.
And he says this is based on a lot of different studies and a lot of different
areas. The
key to what I just said is relatively and so the caveat that I have to add is
that pretty much all of the studies that have been done to date are relatively
small.
He says it's early days and the studies have been done have only been done with
a few subjects,
maybe 20 people, larger studies, 40 or 50
now, a lot of these studies do find a positive effect,
but if you're a hard nose scientist,
you know those small sample sizes aren't enough to make a very big claim.
Even so sure
the truth,
the cats kind of already out of the bag because if you go on youtube,
white flash really brief, really quick, that's cool.
You can find a surprisingly large number of videos of people experimenting with
these devices.
I instantly feel very good, very calm,
very safe, not really worried about anything.
A lot of the videos show you how to make your own course.
We'll start with the circuit diagram and you just go to radio shack and buy a
few simple parts.
There's the battery that's going to be your nine volt and here's a few alligator
clips. Since I don't have any solder with me,
although I have a switch in the circuit.
I mean youtube just seems to be filled with people. Yeah,
we're trying to Hotwire their own brain.
So for the past year I've been wanting to increase my brain power since I have
probably below average a brain power compared to the old beetle.
I want to study neurosciences, but as many of you,
I don't have the resources to go to this school right now.
So what I'd like to do is I like to use tdcs while I'm learning my vocabulary
lists. All right,
so I want to give you an update on using tdcs to learn a foreign language.
People are using this for a whole range of thanksgiving,
how flexible the technique is. That's Nick Fitz. He works with Peter Reiner,
the guy we talked to earlier, and he says,
not only can you do a lot of different kinds of things with this device on top
of that, it's dirt cheap.
So let's say in the time that it takes me to listen to one of your episodes,
I could probably go to the store,
come back and build a tdcs device for around $20 for $20. Right.
And so I'm, as I said, I mean, is that something that makes you nervous? Um,
I'll say first. I think the DIY community is quite thoughtful,
but it does make me nervous.
But there are some people who are that report loss of consciousness after using
it. And there are people that are reporting feeling burns.
There's actually one report of somebody going temporarily blind.
This guy on youtube.
So a young Asian kid I've been experimenting on where, where,
which places on my head would improve memory.
If he talks about how he spent a year kind of experimenting with it,
he put it in one place and after about five minutes, um,
I felt really like really angry and depressed,
but in another place that's a gummy, a really high score on Lumosity.
And I have only been stimulating my brain for about five.
It's like he's playing Russian roulette with that thing. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Which brings up the larger point, you know,
that this devices kind of impossibly hard to regulate because a kid like this
can put it anywhere he wants in his head and if he moves it just a couple of
inches browse, it could have a drastically different effects.
And that's really what is, uh, a concern. Yeah.
Because according to Peter Reiner, while we might like think of the brain
as being a bunch of separate circuits that do separate tasks, really
ecosystem, every part affects every other part in some way.
And when you put your electrodes on the head,
you effect in theory a small area of the brain right under the electrodes.
But it's already been shown that that affects,
can then multiply and spread throughout the nervous system.
Even down to your spinal cord.
I mean, there's a theory out there,
it's called the zero sum theory of the brain that some people use as a framework
for thinking about all this, which is like, you know, one part goes up,
another part goes like, there's only so much juice in the brain.
So if you send juice one direction, there's less juice somewhere else.
So then if you are enhancing one part, you're by definition diminishing another.
Maybe
to be honest, there was definitely an after effect.
This is kind of why I ended up talking to Sally about this,
why I got so interested in this piece in the first place is because of what
happened to her after the sniper training.
So driving down from La to Carlsbad to go do this was an absolute nightmare.
I hadn't driven in like a year cause I've been living in London where I just do
public transportation, but on the way up, uh,
it's kind of like, I mean I hate to compare it to Mario Kart,
but it's just this extremely pleasant experience.
I feel like I drove better that day than I ever drove before.
Like it was very obvious where I could pass people without irritating them and
just, I dunno, it's a weird, it's a weird memory. But I think, um,
I had more fun driving that day than I ever did since.
And at some point she realized it wasn't just about her driving ability.
So I would say that, I mean,
I dunno how much I want to get into sort of in public on the radio about,
you know, being, I'm a bit anxious. I mean,
I guess that's not particularly controversial. Uh,
probably all writers like are sort of riddled with anxiety, but you know,
I have this constant struggle with all the little
angry gnomes in my head, you know,
populating my head and telling me like all the things that I don't do right.
You know, all the things that I've done wrong that day.
They just keep this incredibly like comprehensive tally of them. And then,
you know, the ones who worry about the future. And then, you know,
the ones who tell me I'm going to be living in a cardboard box in a year.
I mean, it's just like an amazing cacophony, but she says sitting in that car,
they were, they were just completely turned off. Um,
I think for a couple of days. And it was a really, you know, really,
I'm sure for a couple of days, for a couple of days. And to tell you the truth,
it's kind of like everything just,
I was just this person that I hadn't experienced before and I thought maybe this
is the actual sort of core person who I am when I'm not,
when all my baggage isn't just weighing on me.
It was like somebody had a wiped,
a really steamy window and I was just able to look at the world for what it was
[inaudible]
and I was curious whether like there's a connection there that like to be a good
performer of some task that goes along with shutting down the parts of yourself
that say, I don't know, I don't sync, maybe I can't, maybe I shouldn't.
And that like there's actually a real connection between amping up one and
tamping down the other. I mean it makes sense cause you're taking,
giving one circuit more power. You might be taken away from other places. Yeah.
It's funny. I mean it does. I find this like, you know,
since you and I are just been on stage for our [inaudible],
one of the things I struggle with most during the performances is I'm sitting
there, we're both sitting there,
we've got our scripts and I have this box of buttons and I have to remember
which buttons do what things and I,
there's like the musicians and it's figuring out where they come in and out and
all of these things. They become competing voices. Yeah.
They become these little chattering gnomes that Sally puts it in my head and I'm
like, wait, wait, what does that, hey, okay, now when does that come in?
Where are we? What? What's happening? Oh my God, you're messing this up, Jack.
Come on. Oh, why did you keep doing it?
And I get like kinda crazy sometimes during a show.
I can't actually even focus on what you're saying. It's not a good feeling.
And then there are other times where something happens almost like commode and
suddenly it's like right there. I know I'm right with you.
It's the easiest thing in the world to listen to what you're saying when respond
instinctively and in the moment and they literally feel like different chemical
modes or maybe electrical modes. You know what I mean? That's really,
that's that I,
that's very interesting to me because I mean going back to the performance
stuff, you can't really make it happen.
I mean I guess you could I suppose, but it doesn't feel that way.
It feels like it's somehow feels like it's a gift, you know? Like,
Oh thank you universe. I feel really awake and present right now. Thank you.
What happens when it's an expectation, you know,
what happened to where are the way in which we move through the world?
If we can just leave, we can create that on demand and order it up. Yeah,
I mean it's,
I think the gift versus ordering it up probably has,
that's pretty deep to me. I mean I don't,
I feel like in a world where you order things up,
then you're in a world where you think you deserve things or you think you've
earned them or you think other people haven't. I agree with that completely.
That's a, it's a word that's a world that's empty of true gratitude.
To tell you the truth. Um,
one of the really worrying things to me was afterward,
how, how much I craved doing it.
It felt like a drug with no side effects. I mean,
I don't know if I'm going to get addicted to electricity.
Seems Unlikely
to get some man shoplifting batteries, some of that going on
in the supermarket corner and licking.
Thank you, sir. No problem. And thanks a lot to Sally [inaudible].
So time to say goodbye. Krulwich Rod, thanks for listening.
Okay.